des coups sur la table comme c'était 7
sont ouverts les places sont d'assez
csla sellal le mot le mot qu'ils disent
est et pour lui c'est anglade à 2 2 mais
branlée la tête
on connaît la menace sur le terrain de
jeu des durs à cuire qui s'en donnent à
coeur joie et qui en paie le prix que
dans leurs rangs les traumatismes
crâniens sont légion il m'a frappé la
tête contre le sol
il s'est mis à me frapper encore m'a
saisie par les cheveux des deux côtés de
la tête dans la frappant contre le sol
pour un joueur de la ligue nationale de
hockey qui subi une commotion cérébrale
des chercheurs estiment qu'au moins 4500
femmes au canada souffre de la même
blessure infligée par un conjoint
violent ça toucherait plus de 200 mille
femmes chaque année au pays une femme
sur trois subir à la violence d'un
conjoint au cours de sa vie et dans plus
de 90% des cas de violence physique
il y aura des coups à la tête au visage
et au cou ou une strangulation
je ne pensais pas qu'il allait arrêter
il m'a donné 20 25 ou à ce type de
violence cause très souvent un
traumatisme crânien et nous savons que
nous donner ne sont que la pointe de
l'iceberg
j'ai eu quand même eu des bons coups
pour un usage ce faisant j'ai eu le seul
à déjouer fritsch et 2 500 j'ai dû me
faire enlever deux dames après la gorge
puis maintenu au mur solidement puis
modifiez pas personne qui qu'il est un
caporal lieutenant de cette façon on
loupe que je serai pas la première non
plus la plupart des recherches portent
sur les athlètes et les jeunes on
prévient on traite on met en place des
protocoles mais un pan entier de la
population est négligé les femmes
victimes de violences conjugales
elles sont pourtant très à risque une
crise de santé publique majeur qui à ce
jour est resté dans l'oubli
[Musique]
quand j'écris je me rapproche de plus en
plus de moi même et de ce que j'ai vécu
par rapport à moi
mais ça me fait du bien de me
reconnecter avec moi et ma propre
douleur des migraines à répétition j'en
avais je vais énormément difficulté à me
concentrer je commençais à quelque chose
puis je me demandais pas que je tente
rennes face au départ sérieusement je
sais aps une patate c'était quelque
chose
daniel hébert a vécu d agression sauvage
pendant des mois et les plaies sont
toujours vives
cet homme avec qui elle entamé une
relation amoureuse dans la cinquantaine
a failli la tuer il ya quatre ans
ligament déchiré au genou
la capsule la vie d'un doigt et les
viols que j'avais subi ces locaux qui
ont diagnostiqué une commotion cérébrale
sévère et mon choc post traumatique
[Musique]
ma seule pensée c'est qu'au dessus de
moi il y avait la chambre de ma fille
j'ai cru qu'il allait me tuer sur place
nous avons également recueilli les
confidences de rich or elle souffre
toujours de l'extrême violence que la
dépuille à trois ans aux mains de son ex
conjointe nous avons accepté de protéger
son identité pour des raisons de
sécurité
[Musique]
à l'hôpital je me suis effondrée crown
of thorns à roswell
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai ressenti
une vive douleur je serai payne je
n'avais jamais eu aussi mal à la tête
les chiffres sont mirobolants
c'est effectivement une très vaste
proportion de femmes qui vont sur de la
violence conjugale dans leur vie c'est
resté soudé tu dis surtout les séquelles
de cela louez de beaumont et neuro
psychologue et professeur au département
de chirurgie de l'université de montréal
le cerveau des sportifs il analyse sous
toutes ses coutures
lorsqu'on en jetant un coup de sang ici
à la taille très fort avec un certain
angle le cerveau ce premier dans la
boîte crânienne et allait se heurter
contre les parois la boîte crânienne
un des impacts plus important c'est
justement sur les accents des neuf ans
les actions celui des field
communication entre les différentes
régions du cerveau qui tendent à être
plus affectée par les commotions général
parce qu'elles sont étirées et elle se
déchire
il peut avoir une diminution de la
connexion d'enfants dans différentes
régions du cerveau dont une qui ont
résulté ensuite à une perte
fonctionnelle pour la personne donc
aborder ces quelques années
[Musique]
emma et milieu il faut un jour suivant
ça moi je ne pouvais pas supporter la
lumière du jour plus de 10 minutes sans
avoir la nausée des étourdissements maux
tête insomnie bourdonnements dans les
oreilles
[Musique]
le traumatisme crânien qu'elle subit
brych all à freiner son élan de carrière
en tant que cadre au gouvernement il
empêche d'accomplir des gestes simples
[Musique]
nous avons voulu en savoir plus sur les
traumatismes crâniens chez les victimes
de violences conjugales
de nombreuses femmes ont accepté de se
confier à nous il avait subi de gros
coups à la tête mais il ya toutes celles
qui reçoivent de petits coups à
répétition derrière des portes closes
mais qui reste dans l'ombre ce week end
à nantes à loches par exemple à
l'arrière de la tête mais mon cerveau
quand même bougerait dans la boîte
crânienne pas suffisamment pour piéger
des symptômes d'une commotion cérébrale
mais assez peu taillé pour faire du
dommage si ce nombre de couleurs
s'accumulent
nous comprenons les commotions dans un
contexte sportif crax line vague est une
pionnière dans la recherche sur le sujet
au canada doctorante en travail social à
l'université wilfrid laurier en ontario
elle a développé un site web à
l'intention des intervenantes dans les
maisons d'hébergement et des victimes on
sent chez elle
l'urgence d'agir une des leçons que l'on
peut tirer du sport et la gravité des
blessures répétitives et l'importance de
les éviter
nous pensons que ce facteur augmente le
risque pour les femmes exposées à la
violence de leur conjoint
dans bien des cas elle se retrouve de
nouveau dans une situation de violence
dans les heures les jours ou les
semaines qui suivent
après jean angie
sidney crosby n'a toujours pas retrouvé
sa forme et ressent toujours les
symptômes de sa commotion cérébrale
subie en janvier
[Musique]
actuellement on s'assure qu'une personne
souffrant d'une commotion cérébrale à la
suite d'une activité sportive d'une
chute ou d'un accident de voiture se
retire de cette activité
on lui permet de se reposer avant de
reprendre des activités physiques
nos premières analyses indiquent que les
femmes qui souffrent d'un traumatisme
crânien liés à la violence de leur
conjoint ont beaucoup plus de symptômes
que les jeunes athlètes qui viennent de
subir une commotion paul lasne kinkela
et chercheur en neurosciences cliniques
à l'université de la
colombie-britannique à kelowna car
amazon a longtemps dirigé un refuge pour
femmes victimes de violence conjugale
ils forment un couple et réalise un des
rares projets de recherche dans le
domaine au canada les femmes nous disent
souvent j'ai des trous de mémoire
j'oublie des rendez vous j'emmène mes
enfants à l'école en retard je dors mal
organisé j'ai du mal à gérer mes
émotions
plusieurs femmes nous ont dit qu'elles
ont toujours cru que c'était de leur
faute ce que leurs partenaires leur a
dit pendant des années qu'elles sont
stupides incompétente de mauvaises mères
mais on n'a jamais pensé qu'elle pouvait
souffrir d'une blessure physique ils ont
élaboré une formation en ligne en
anglais et en français mme pour
favoriser le dépistage du plus grand
nombre de femmes possible dans les
maisons d'hébergement
on se demande souvent pourquoi ne parte
elle pas la question pourrait plutôt se
poser c'est pourquoi la frappe t-il
lorsqu'on y ajoute un traumatisme
crânien vous avez là une femme qui ne
peut pas fonctionner à pleine capacité
ça pourrait dans la mener à rester plus
longtemps et à subir d'autres blessures
rien de mon image que l'on voit deux
femmes aux visages meurtris et couvert
de bleus ne représente pas ce qui se
passe vraiment il y à des coûts qui sont
donnés sous les cheveux et les
ecchymoses sont invisibles
la violence conjugale mène souvent à la
strangulation
quand on coupe la circulation du sang et
d'oxygène au cerveau
ça peut très vite provoqué un
traumatisme crânien sans même laisser de
marque à la gorge
c'est toujours demain la gauche soit sur
le lit soit un soin au mur mais c'est
toujours deux mains à la gorge qui me
ment pêche de respirer j'ai perdu
connaissance sous 20 l'excès de main à
la gorge
est-ce que vous avez une idée de combien
de fois a pas que j'ai perdu
connaissance
régulièrement régulièrement c'était
quand même fréquent
on
c'est le premier réflexe une femme qui
est victime de violences
c'est de banaliser souvent les violences
qu'elles ont vécu parce que ça fait des
amis calypso les traumatismes crâniens
passe souvent sous le radar dans bien
des cas les victimes elles mêmes
ignorent leur condition manon monastesse
les directrices de la fédération des
maisons d'hébergement pour femmes 7 et
30 ans qu'elle travaille dans le domaine
les temps lié avec l'âme
la réponse du système médical qui ne
fait pas les liens de ces traumatismes
loca même quand ils savent que c'est
arrivé en contexte de violence conjugale
vous allez chez le médecin ces 20
minutes top chrono
alors pour commencer à élargir la
discussion
élargir l'intervention faible dépistage
les experts du milieu que nous avons
consultés ont constaté qu'on a tendance
à voir la condition des femmes sous
l'angle de la santé mentale de stress
post traumatique par exemple et reconnus
et traités mais on examine rarement les
conséquences des traumatismes granier
pourquoi ces femmes ont-elles des mots
tête pendant de longues périodes
pourquoi ont-elles du mal à ce qu'un
centre et sans l'imputent à l'anxiété au
stress post traumatique ou à d'autres
problèmes de santé mentale plutôt qu'à
une condition comme un traumatisme
crânien comme si on ne traite que la
dépression et le stress post traumatique
il se prive de toutes les possibilités
de soutien et de réadaptation offerte
pour les traumatismes crâniens
pendant des années nous avons travaillé
côte à côte en silo le centre creed à
victoria en colombie-britannique a été
fondé il ya 150 ans par un évêque
anglican
aujourd'hui l'organisme vient en aide
aux victimes de violences conjugales et
aux aînés entre autres les traumatisés
crâniens surtout des hommes qui ont subi
un avc ou un accident de la route
profite aussi de leurs services il y a
quatre ans on a créé un programme de
jumelage unique dans le domaine de
l'intervention sociale
nous étions privilégiés de travailler
pour un organisme qui offrait déjà des
services dans ces deux domaines
nous avons commencé avec un groupe de
cinq femmes et nous sommes maintenant
passés à 10 quand de stretch et toribash
travaille en étroite collaboration
leur mission accompagner les femmes au
quotidien les survivantes ont souvent
des problèmes d'exécution fonctionnel
d'accomplissement tâche on les aide à
prendre et à respecter les rendez-vous à
tenir un agenda à remplir des
formulaires à a passé un coup de
téléphone flash les équipes ont adapté
leurs interventions conçu pour les
traumatisés crâniens aux victimes de
violences conjugales
ils se marchent d'abord les
intervenantes en violence conjugale vont
dépister les signes et les symptômes
d'un traumatisme crânien chez une
victime puis de notre côté on se charge
d'élaborer un plan de soutien plus
efficace pour elles ont leur trouvions
souvent du soutien du côté de la santé
mentale et de la toxicomanie
durant les trois ans qu'elle passait
dans nos logements est le constat était
criant de changer pour elle
enzo nouvelle approche a changé la donne
depuis que nous avons recours à ses
services
nous voyons de bien meilleurs résultats
chez ces femmes ça a eu un effet
transformateurs des stigmatisant et
libérateur pour les femmes qui ont
participé au programme les outils de
dépistage qui font partie de l'arsenal
de soins des athlètes et des accidentés
de la route commence timidement faire
leur chemin dans les maisons
d'hébergement au canada il assuma
redirige le refuge pour femmes de
l'ouest de l'île le des premiers au
québec à adopter une nouvelle approche
mais était pour nous c'est sûr que ça
fait la différence dans notre pratique
parce que on est à l'ère à ce qu'on
l'intègre on en voit plus essayez de
l'observer puis de voir adresse avec la
femme au québec
est ce que tu veux qu'on est ce que tu
vas parler à ton médecin ce que tu veux
qu'on t'a compagnie pour toi finalement
qu'on va pouvoir utiliser au quotidien
on va fort aussi par son neurologue
blessé dans un accident de voiture
fatima ensuite subi de la violence
conjugale son ex conjoint est visé par
des accusations de voies de fait simples
mais il a plaidé non coupable
elle compte sur l'aide du refuge pour
retourner aux études
sirtou lymphatique avec la fatigue ouais
ouais je me sens toujours fatigué des
sensibilité à la lumière et au bruit ou
des troubles vision et je ne voyais pas
bien c'est des tâches
est-ce que c'est flou c'est flou où s
est correctement sa voix sur ce que je
veux c'est ma santé
ouais et d'être normal qu avant
on a un devoir en tant que maison
d'hébergement d'investiguer d'éclairer
la femme pitt d'en parler pour essayer
d'avoir plus de soutien pour ces
femmes-là bien qu'elle arrive un peu
partout dans toutes nos tout les
systèmes bâti je pense qu'il faut qu'il
ya un accueil auxerre ce nouveau lieu au
même titre qu'on le fait pour les
sportifs il ya très peu de recherches
qui étaient faits sur les femmes
victimes de violences conjugales qui
implique des coups à la tête
souvent parce que c'est plus compliqué
ça va impliquer des facteurs sociaux
beaucoup plus complexe que celui de la
commotion cérébrale jeune athlète de
haut niveau la même façon qu'on étudie
portant les boxeurs on n'hésite pas
beaucoup parce qu'il ya des fois des
enjeux sociétaux semble complexe que
celui d'un athlète un joueur d'orgue et
qui viennent une famille fonctionner
leurs collègues en septembre 2019 les
ministères de la santé de l'éducation du
québec ont lancé des travaux autour
d'une stratégie nationale sur les
commotions cérébrales
outre les jeunes et les sportifs ont dit
vouloir cibler d'autres gros cette
stratégie nationale va permettre
vraiment d'intégrer
les personnes âgées nous avons appris
qu'aucun représentant issu des milieux
des deux victimes de violence conjugale
n'avait été invité à y participer
le ministère de la santé nous assure
aujourd'hui qu'on va désormais tenir
compte de ces femmes
les ministres responsables ont refusé
nos demandes d'entrevue
il faut qu'ils aient de la formation 1
continue j'étais ici à montréal dans un
hôpital département de gynécologie
obstétrique et j'ai vu des affiches qui
date des années 80 qui parlait de la
violence conjugale les affiches d'été
des premières début 80 85 90 des
premières campagnes de sensibilisation
daniel essaie de tourner la page après
la condamnation à la prison de son ex
conjointe c'est aussi le cas de red bull
dont l'ex a plaidé coupable pour ses
gestes mais j'arrive à faire plus de
choses maintenant mais je ne peux
toujours pas faire tourner ma fille en
dansant je ne pense pas que ça revienne
[Musique]
les femmes vont subir des effets à plus
long terme des commotions cérébrales
donc leurs symptômes vont tendre a duré
plus longtemps et à être plus sévère
on commence à étudier pendant les effets
des hormones lors de l'impact
la preuve est faite quand on reçoit des
coups répétés à la tête
il ya des risques à long terme de
développer des maladies
neurodégénératives comme
l'encéphalopathie traumatique chronique
le tc fait les manchettes depuis ton la
découverte il ya une vingtaine d'années
en étudiant le cerveau d'athlètes mort
prématurément une femme sur huit au
canada peut s'attendre à souffrir d'un
cancer du sein pensons aux ressources
financières aux soutiens aux soins
médicaux qui sont dédiés et ce à juste
titre et quand on pense aux sommes
consacrées à cet enjeu ce n'est même pas
comparable à quelques niveaux que ce
soit en lna
[Musique]
sur les rapports médicaux qu'est ce que
tu écris c'est écrit séquelles
permanentes
donc le travail on oublie ça
malheureusement
salut sam bien pu comme un vin mais je
tire ça me vient pu aussi facile comme
avant de juste m'asseoir donc prendre un
café clé sans fin je regarde des fois
pour dray qui voit pas la manie personne
je le suis plus non plus mais j'aimerais
que souviennent de qui je t'aime
[Musique]
on